hi I'm Elijah Wood and I'm doing the
wired autocomplete interview why is
Elijah Wood hot what I didn't know that
I was and I don't know how to answer
that question but thanks my parents have
Daniel Radcliffe and Elijah Wood met yes
when we were doing ADR for one of the
Lord of the Rings films and they were
shooting Prisoner of Azkaban the third
Harry Potter film from we got to go
visit the set
I met him then but I don't know that
I've met him since but I certainly get
asked if I am him a lot which I find
really amusing and it doesn't bother me
at all
seriously does Elijah Wood play
spider-man in the movie no I'm gonna
play the video game that's good how did
they make Elijah Wood small in Lord of
the Rings I'm assuming it was a variety
of different things so there'd be an
entire sequence that would be shot
without us and then we would with a
motion control camera more often than
not we would then go into a blue-screen
unit and sort of fit ourselves into that
same shot we'd be Compton that was one
way we also had scale doubles and people
who were about the height of hobbits
that would wear our outfits and also
masks of our face which was pretty
disturbing they were incredible and they
they did a lot of our work for a lot of
the wide stuff occasionally there was
force perspective that was used so a
good example of that would be Frodo and
Gandalf from the carp in Bag End in the
first film
Frodo jumps under the cart and they're
sitting side-by-side I was actually
sitting slightly behind Ian McKellen and
Ian McKellen was sat slightly ahead of
us and the camera was placed in such a
way that it looked like we were sitting
side-by-side with him taller than I you
look at the monitor and we were sitting
next to each other and he was giant I
was small which was pretty magical it's
a super old-fashioned trick that totally
works now and then there was like one
sequence that we ended up abandoning in
this technology but they made these sort
of big people on stilts but in like
large human outfits with like
articulated fake hands
we only used it once it proved to be
effective in the background the if you
see when they're trying to check into
the Prancing Pony under the name
Underhill you see a few people walk by
those are these sort of like people on
stilts and giant outfits essentially and
they ended up abandoning that they
didn't use it as much because it wasn't
super practical anyway it's long answer
multiple tools in that particular
toolbox did Ian McKellan in the logic
would film scenes together yes we shot
all of our scenes together so anytime
that the hobbits were with anyone that
were larger than them
we would always be together it's just
occasionally we'd not be able to look
each other in the eye like you would
normally look sometimes we'd be on our
knees to look small and we could
interact and but we were always in
scenes together it's just in terms of
how we would be placed in front of the
camera to appear small or large what was
Elijah woods first movie it was a tiny
tiny role and back to the future - there
is a scene in the cafe 80s and there are
two kids at the back of the cafe 80s
trying to play this like gunslinger game
with a light gun Michael J Fox comes up
and explains it to them and then like
shoots a bunch of things and does really
well at the game and the kids make fun
of him cuz they're like this is what you
have to use your hands anyway that was
the first thing I ever did
what does he Elijah would look like now
what nationality is Elijah wood-boring
American I mean if there's heritage that
goes way back but my nationality is yes
there's like a little bit of Danish in
me a little bit of English but that goes
way back what does he legit would eat
[Laughter]
it's a difficult question to answer I
could say a lot of different things
Pizza is probably my favorite food my
girlfriend and I we eat a fair amount of
pizza it become it's obsessive I also
really love frozen pizza it's a little
bit of a thing I going to like new
supermarkets
you've never been to and seeing new
brands of frozen pizza that you've never
seen before you like yeah I gotta give
that a go there are certain frozen pizza
brands that I won't with but Han I love
a good frozen pizza
but did Elijah would keep from rings I
have the one ring I have a pair of latex
Hobbit feet they're in good shape sting
the sword I have a slate from from the
films as well can Elijah would sing I'm
not tone-deaf but I don't think I can
sing very well I'm always pretty shot at
sing karaoke and need a little
lubrication in order to get the
confidence to do it I don't know I've
been told I can sing I don't have a
great deal of confidence in it
I did actually audition for Moulin Rouge
so I took singing lessons for that and
the audition consisted of me singing two
songs there's a videotape of ebbets got
to be pretty impaired say oh man Elijah
Wood can and may that's cool that's
actually really old reference if that's
what it is the first large role that I
had enough film was a movie called
Avalon I was eight years old there's a
whole sequence where the character that
I played can't distinguish the
difference between can and may and he
ends up like going to the principal's
office because of it or gets like sent
out of class because he he just can't
understand that the difference so I can
and I'm a maybe I can can Elijah Wood
playing the piano I took lessons when I
was young like a lot of kids do instead
of reading the music and I'd play from
memory which is cool you know a good
thing sort of but it's a really bad
habit so I wouldn't necessarily remember
everything correctly I think I was like
13 or 14 not quit and then I ended up
having to have like a crash course in
playing piano for a movie called grand
piano because the character that I
played was an incredible pianist I could
play a little bit but not to anywhere
that degree I didn't walk out of that
knowing how to play any better
necessarily but I got really good at
fitting my hands in the right place at
the right time it was fun it was really
really scary Kenny lied you would drive
a stick-shift I mean I've done it twice
for work but they were crash courses
like you've got to do this now for this
scene I mean the last time I did it I
almost went out of gear and then very
intensely put my foot on the accelerator
and I
to successfully not hit anything and
stop I need to take lessons because
there's some really great cars that only
drive stick and I can't drive them does
Elijah Wood have a personal life well of
course I table I mean I'm a record
collector I DJ from time to time
watching movies my girlfriend and I we
had all of these movies that we'd never
seen and this sort of collective shame
list pretty significant films like I had
never seen a Kurosawa film so we thought
well let's put it together a Film
Festival for us to catch up on these
movies and we'll invite friends we did
that it was really fun does Elijah Wood
age yeah I do I get asked this question
a lot
I definitely age I have gray hair maybe
not as many wrinkles as one would have
at 39 I don't know it's all relative
does Elijah Wood do magic tricks I used
to when I was a kid I learned a couple
of card tricks
that were relatively fun and and you've
some somewhat easy but I've since
forgotten them so now I don't do any
magic tricks does Elijah would have
dichromatic
eyes enough another both blue both the
same shade of blue I think does Elijah
would wear wings in life no for work
occasionally okay is Elijah Wood a twin
no not that I know of maybe there's like
an unknown twin or a doppelganger out
there is Elijah Wood a DJ yeah I started
sort of casually doing it way back in a
lot of the Rings days and then
officially sort of jumped into to
records about I guess 10 years ago maybe
a little bit less the thing about vinyl
that's so exciting is that it is a
physical object so things can go wrong
and you have to be at the ready to fix
that problem sonically
and so you're always on your toes
there's nothing lazy about it's very
active and I just love that it's really
fun
is Elijah Wood vegan no man so sorry
don't mean to be offensive to any vegans
I love food too much but yeah veganism
isn't
I mean you can't eat honey for instance
honey's delicious is Elijah Wood
left-handed no I'm not left-handed I'm
right-handed which is a good thing
because I did fall in this particular
hand and it was out of commission for
about three months so that would have
been a bummer
if I was left-handed if CH it would
related to Evan Rachel Wood I don't
think we are related but we could be
related as far back to England my
heritage goes back to England and
Ireland and there's a good chance that
hers could go back there as well in
which case distantly we could be you
never know Elijah Wood is stealing your
socks is that really something that
someone wrote on Google how do they know
that I was so discreet Jesus is this the
last board not the last word where is
Elijah Wood today like right now I'm I'm
doing this so I'm here today but when
you when you watch this I won't be here
I'll be somewhere else
I can't answer that question for you
contextually based on where you are
watching this now I could be anywhere I
don't know where did he large a would
grow up I grew up in California I was
born in Iowa and moved to Los Angeles
when I was seven
I've lived here ever since where are did
Elijah would go to college I didn't go
to college
my university time was taken up in
Middle Earth it was four years of my
life was taken up making those films I
also don't know that I would have gone
to university because I didn't graduate
high school didn't even get the GED
which I often did thing to do like maybe
I should just do this so I can get I can
graduate and I didn't do it that is not
a good idea though like graduate high
school
don't don't follow my footsteps graduate
please where does the larger would live
I live in Southern California and
occasionally I live in Austin Texas okay
who does Elijah Wood look like
apparently a lot like Daniel Radcliffe
and occasionally like Tobey Maguire who
are
rigel woods parents my mom's name is
Debra and my dad's name is Warren that's
the that's not who is a larger wood in
Sin City
I play Kevin in Sin City who is a mute
very religiously fanatical and the kind
of questionable way cannibal who is he
larger would married to I'm not married
yet one day who delights hood voice in
God of War I'd completely forgotten I
said a voice with that apparently Kratos
brother demios and I remember I was
killed and I get my head ripped off I
had to scream that was yeah I dig lis
remember that I was so long ago
that's it